[Musique]
bonsoir et heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 78 le journal voici les
titres inauguration de l'extension du
centre de recherche INRIA sac situé à
palzo hier 2 ans de travaux pour créer
6000 m car cela permettra d'accueillir
de nouveaux chercheurs nous étions sur
place grand corps malade é hier soir à
l'UGC de Saint-Quentin en Eveline le
slamer a présenté son tout premier film
les patients en avant-première un long
métrage déjà récompensé de trois prix au
Festival du film de Sarla et puis le
Japon est à l'honneur à la maison de
quartier Auguste Renoir de gu en cours
durant les vacances plusieurs ateliers
sont mis en place pour permettre aux
plus jeunes de découvrir le pays du
soleil
levant on ouvre ce journal avec le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher
l'ivnois a de nouveau défendu François
Fillon ce matin sur l'antenne de BFM TV
il estime que toute sa formation est en
ordre de marche derrière le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle le président
du Sénat a également évoqué un accord
politique qui devrait voir le jour
rapidement avec les fidèles de Nicolas
Sarkozi ils se sont expliqués et ça
n'est pas illégitime de faire part des
difficultés qui ont été rencontrées sur
le terrain l'ignier n'aurait aucun sens
il y a eu débat il y a eu échange et
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
parlementaires des groupes les
républicains sont derrière François
Fillon il en est de même je le sais de
la plupart des parlementaires udi et
d'ici quelques jours il y aura un accord
politique car le comité politique que je
préside c'est celui des républicains le
14 février a eu lieu l'inauguration de
l'extension du centre de recherche INRIA
sacleèb situé à palzo les 1200 m Carr du
bâtiment pourront accueillir les 450
collabor orateur de linria et surtout
renforcer le pôle
scientifique c'est en 2002 que nî l'idée
de créer le centre de recherche de
l'inrias à CLA et surtout de l'agrandir
l'idée est enfin devenue une réalité
après 2 ans de travaux le bâtiment Alan
Turing s'est agrandi et fait maintenant
12000 m Carr il y a plusieurs équipes
qui étaient logées ailleurs qui sont
maintenant dans ce bâtiment on on a
aussi des plateformes de recherche et
d'expérimentation qui sont installées
une plateforme de capteur sans fil par
exemple fit qui est installé ici euh
d'autres plateformes des ressources de
calcul supplémentaires qui sont dans une
salle machine et puis un amphithéâtre
tout neuf pour recevoir des conférences
des colloques des réunions et cetera
cette extension permettra d'accueillir
12 équipes du centre INRIA ainsi que H8
équipe du laboratoire informatique de
Polytechnique l'École polytechnique qui
est partenaire de ce projet comme
l'Université Paris Sud le but est de
créer une émulation entre les chercheurs
la base de ce que nous faisons c'est de
l'excellence scientifique he il faut
qu'on soit parmi les meilleurs au monde
mais chez INRIA nous essayons de faire
en sorte que cette excellence
scientifique elle ait un impact
c'est-à-dire elle est un impact ou bien
vers le monde industriel ou bien vers le
monde de la société parce qu'encore une
fois les technologies que nous
développons elles ont des applications
dans à peu près tous les secteurs de
l'économie mais elles ont aussi des
applications dans le domaine de la santé
dans le domaine de l'environnement dans
le domaine de la cybersécurité autant de
préoccupations qui sont plus des
préoccupations sociales que des
préoccupations industrielles
avec ce nouveau bâtiment linria souhaite
continuer à compléter ses équipes avec
des mécaniciens et des chercheurs en
sciences et cette inauguration
intervient au moment où la Cour des
comptes a épinglé la mauvaise gestion de
Paris Saint-Clair la semaine dernière
écouz la réaction de Michel Bourn
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de Paris saint-clais la
Cour des comptes pointe des des
faiblesses mais à côté de ça il y a des
enjeux qui sont positifs pour pour
l'université Paris- sain-clay et puis
passer sous silence à tous les enjeux
d'aménagement du territoire il suffit de
voir les grues sur le territoire avec la
réalisation des projets de de
construction pour accueillir les
établissements d'enseignement pour
accueillir les étudiants pour accueillir
les futurs habitants pour accueillir les
entreprises l'interview complète dans le
78 les invités du jour 2e édition du
budget participatif à morpa après le vif
succès de sa première édition la mairie
a décidé de réitérer l'expérience la
première édition avait déboucher sur la
construction d'un skateepk vous avez
jusqu'au 1er mars pour déposer votre
projet sur le site internet de la
ville cinéma à présent grand corps
malade était hier soir à l'UGC de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline en
avant-première le virtuose Desmo a
présenté son premier film son premier
film les patients un longmétrage déjà
récompensé de trois prix au Festival du
film de Sarla et qui sera à l'affiche le
1er mars un reportage de Michel elmidoro
et d'Alice
Deschamp c'était l'événement hier soir à
l'UGC de 50 ans en yeline l'équipe du
film les patients est venu à la
rencontre du public pour présenter sa
comédie dramatique en avant-première le
longmétrage réalisé par le slamer grand
corp malade raconte l'histoire d'un
jeune homme devenu tétraplégique suite à
un grave accident une histoire tirée de
l'expérience personnelle de l'artiste
tous les personnages du film ont existé
toutes les scènes je les ai vécues voilà
seulement moi je m'appelle Fabien dans
la vie le personnage s'appelle ben
l'idée c'était de ça m'intéressait pas
de faire un biopic sur Grand Corps
Malade ou sur ce qui était grand corps
malade avant de faire de la musique donc
l'idée c'était de rendre le personnage
un peu plus universelle pour mettre en
scène le film Grand Corps Malade a
partagé la réalisation avec medyir son
ami depuis 12 ans avec qui il a
travaillé sur des clips des
documentaires et des courtmétrages on a
vu qu'on était très très souvent raccord
et qu'on avait surtout un cerveau pour
deux du coup ça nous a permis d'arriver
en préparation avec nos équipes on
savait déjà exactement ce qu'on voulait
faire pendant près de 2 heur le public
plonge dans le quotidien du handicap le
personnage principal ben doit
réapprendre tous les gestes du quotidien
et accepter sa situation en parallèle il
se fait de nouveaux amis dans le centre
de rééducation une histoire qui devrait
selon les réalisateurs permettre de
briser des tabous dans le film à un
moment il y a le personnage de faride
qui dit à ben tu verras au départ les
gens ils te voient que comme un
handicapé ce sera toujours ta première
identité et seulement après ils vont
découvrir il y a quelqu'un qui se cache
derre le fauteuil il a il peut y avoir
un handicapé beau un handicapé Kaira un
handicapé qui de l'humour un gros con
voilà comme comme comme chez les autres
quoi et du coup bah j'espère que ce film
ça ce sera un peu ça au départ on est
plongé dans le monde du handicap dans ce
centre de rééducation on apprend
beaucoup de choses sur le handicap et
sur ce que c'est que le quotidien de
personnes qui sont pas du tout autonomes
sortie officielle du film le 1er mars
avec l'objectif d'atteindre au minimum
300000 entrées pour rentabiliser la
production pour les vacances scolaires
le musée rambolitrain à Rambouillet se
modernise à découvrir un jeu sur les
lumières et une exposition temporaire
qui attire petits et grands de nuit
comme de jour la gare du musée
rambolitraain est en marche un nouvel
éclairage LED plus proche de la réalité
par des couchés de soleil c'est la
nouveauté pour ces vacances on a
beaucoup travaillé là ces derniers temps
sur le réseau maquette qui se trouve
derrière nous au niveau de la ville un
peu plus loin sur les éclairages pour
mettre en valeur tout ce beau travail
accomplis par les maquettistes donc on a
mis des éclairages LED on peut changer
en fait faire varier les couleurs on
peut donner une ambiance lever du jour
une ambiance jour et une ambiance par
exemple coucher de soleil wagon passager
ou wagons remplis de marchandises
l'exposition temporaire pour les
vacances scolaires prend place et cache
de nombreuses anecdotes de ces wagons
ont prélevé parfois à chaque fois qu'il
s'arrêtait dans une gare les les
cheminaux avaient parfois la mauvaise
habitude de prélever quelques litres de
de spirituel de vin qui se trouv à
l'intérieur alors c'était tout simple on
prenait une petite chignole et puis
voilà on perçait un petit trou à
l'intérieur on rebouchait ensuite
aujourd'hui on trouve plus ces wagons
bifoud ou foudre mais voilà c'était
intéressant puis c'est toujours drôle de
raconter cette histoire à nos visiteurs
ça leur plaît beaucoup le clou du
spectacle la locomotive à vapeur datant
des années 50 un retour en enfance pour
certains surtout pour les papis retour
en enfance si ça nous rappelle bah nos
enfants à Noël le Père Noël app porté
les trains électriques on est venu au
musée aujourd'hui ce qu'on voulait
occupé notre grand garçon de 4 ans
pendant les vacances scolaires et comme
on habite dans les ivlines et adore les
trains on a trouvé sur internet ce musée
et voilà pourquoi on est venu en famille
le musée souhaite à l'avenir s'agrandir
et se moderniser pour conquérir les plus
jeunes
générations la maison de quartier
Auguste Renoir de guencour vous propose
de découvrir pendant les vacances le
Japon la ville propose un stage de
découverte du du pays du soleil levant
plusieurs ateliers sont proposés aux
plus jeunes nous avons suivi le premier
cours lundi après-midi un visage rond ou
oval et de grands yeux expressifs
dessiner un manga ça s'apprend maricou
est japonaise et dessinatrice elle
devient aujourd'hui professeur de manga
pour ses jeunes de Guill en cours on
peut savoir beaucoup de choses dans le
manga moi aussi j'aielé beaucoup de
choses de la vie par manga émotion
relation des
gens comment ça peut permettre accès
facilement dans le manga jusqu'au
vendredi on va essayer de réaliser
chacun un petit manga une page et il
vont inventer le personnage chacun et
puis on va faire petite scénario arrivé
en France dans les années 90 le manga
sétaillé une place de choix dans la
culture populaire 12 adolescents
participent à cet atelier yayera et sa
sœur sont venus perfectionner leur
techniques moi j'en ai déjà dessiné mais
je connaissais pas les techniques donc
là je suis venu ici pour en apprendre
plus c'est beaucoup mieux avec les
techniques parce qu'avant c'était pas
très facile le dessin c'était pas trop
mon truc mais j'ai mais après quand ma
sœur elle a dit il y a stage manga j'ai
j'ai dit bon ben je vais juste essayer
mais là quand je fais je dis c'est
amusant donc c'est j'aime bien au-delà
de l'aspect artistique ce stage se veut
une découverte culturelle du Japon la
semaine sera ponctuée d'ateliers cuisine
et calligraphie pour tout connaître sur
le Pays du Soleil
Levant et le château de Versailles
propose aussi des activités en cette
période de de vacances
scolaires une exposition fête et
divertissement à la cour est à découvrir
jusqu'au 26 mars une activité qui fait
revivre le château en famille reportage
de de Alice Deschamps et de Mathilde
demi transmettre l'histoire échanger
dans des lieux mythiques c'est
l'objectif de l'exposition fê et
divertissement à la cour de Versailles
parmi les roi et les reennes du château
les enfants abordent l'histoire de façon
ludique donc on part à la découverte de
cette exposition à la fois on explique
l'histoire de ces divertissements et à
la fois on les on les fait
participer avec des petits jeux par
exemple d'odeur pour la chasse les
remettre dans l'ambiance avec des
recherches dans les salles de certains
instruments de musique selon des
descriptions ça permet aussi de de de de
donner un aspect ludique à l'exposition
et justement c'est le thème de cette
exposition donc ça marche plutôt bien
mais qui est Marie Antoinette c'est en
abordant les portraits les objets mais
aussi les loisirs à travers les salles
que les enfants comprennent les
habitudes les activités et même la
cruauté de
l'époque décapitée elle a été
décapitée alors
guillotiné avec une machine que l'on
appelle la guillotine ce qui fonctionne
bien je dirais que c'est la partie
jardin parce qu'on on voit vraiment des
des jeux notamment les ptins glace ça ça
marche bien parce qu'on a un repère
aussi par rapport au à nos activités
d'aujourd'hui aussi le les jeux de
société voilà avec les exemple de jeux
de cavagnol par exemple ils aiment
toujours bien jouer avec les petites
billes avec les petites olives ils se
mettent vraiment en contexte un cadre
idylique pour s'amuser mais aussi pour
apprendre l'histoire des rois de France
dès le plus jeune
âge c'est la fin de ce c le journal
bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]